العالم كله حرفيا اليوم ما له عنوان او
سيره الا ترامب واخبار ترامب واستدعاء
ومحاكمته والموضوع بدا فعليا من امس من
وقت رحلته مع عدد من مساعديه ومستشاري من
فلوريدا مقر اقامته الى مطار لجوعديا في
نيويورك مكان المحاكمه على متن طائرته
الخاصه الطائره اللي اطلق عليها اسم
ترامبو
الرئاسيه المخصصه للرئيس الامريكي الرحله
هذه كانت الاكثر تتبعا في جميع انحاء
العالم وفقا لفلايت رادار وشاهد التغطيات
مباشره من اغلب القنوات الاجنبيه والعربيه
اللي تابعتها لحظه بلحظه على مدى ساعتين
ونص وتم استقباله في مطار لجوه من قبل
الخدمه السريه الخاصه فيه وتم ايصاله الى
برج ترامب حيث يقيم وحيث كان يقيم ايام ما
كانت مقر اقامته في نيويورك تحت حراسه
امنيه مشدده
طيب مشاهدينا الان خلينا ننقلكم الى صور
مباشره من مطار
حيث طبعا هناك لسه في انتظار طائره الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انها تهبط
اللي هي الطائره اللي قلنا لكم انه اسمها
طبعا الطائره ما زال امامها ساعه تقريبا
الى الوصول ولكن كل شاشات العالم
بتراقب هذه اللحظه وفي كثير شاشات جلسه
بتنقل هذا المشهد لايف فقط في انتظار لحظه
وصول
الطائره ونزول ترامب منها وطبعا
ذهاب الى مقر اقامته في بالم بيتش اللي هو
حيث المتوقع ان يلقي كلمه مهمه جدا امام
انصاره
طبعا الاهتمام هذا انعكس من شاشات
التلفزيون للمنصات في ترند اول حول العالم
وبمختلف اللغات والناس بتتابع وبتترقب
وبتحاول تفهم ايش اللي راح يصير وبتبحث عن
معلومات واخبار تقدر من خلالها تفهم
القضيه او ايش اللي بيواجه ترامب على جوجل
شوفوا امامكم الزياده في البحث عن اسم
ترامب خلال يوم واحد بس هذا غير الزياره
بالالاف في او زياده بالالاف عفوا في
المئه في نسب البحث عن كل ما يتعلق في
المحاكمه مواضيع الاعتقال والمحاكمه في
المراتب الاولى في البحث على جوجل وزاد
البحث عليها
180% اما الاسئله على جوجل فكل ما يخص
التهم ضده واعتقاله واستدعائه زاد البحث
عنه بالالاف في المئه والمئات في المئه
الموضوع طبعا مفهوم ومو غريب يعني رئيس
امريكي سابق توجه له توهم جنائيه يعني هذا
الموضوع غير مسبوق ومهم وحتى اي نتكلم عن
واحد من اكثر الرؤساء الجدليه مو بس في
تاريخ امريكا بل في تاريخ العالم ككل في
كل اللي فات من حلقتنا ناقشنا الاحداث
والوقائع على الارض واللي بيصير فعليا لكن
في جزئيه ما نقدر ما نناقشها لما نتكلم عن
قضيه ترامب وممكن نختصرها بسؤال بسيط
انتصار للديمقراطيه ولا انهيار هذا اللي
جالس بيصير حاليا في شريحه كبير من الناس
شايفه اللي بيصير انتصار للديمقراطيه او
دليل انه ما في احد فوق القانون لكن على
الناحيه الثانيه في كثار شايفين الموضوع
مؤامره ضد ترامب ومحاوله لاستغلال الموضوع
وتلفيق او تركيب قضيه ما لها اساس لمنع من
الترشح مجددا وكثار من هؤلاء بطبيعه الحال
ديمقراطيين بمعنى الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه الدكتور احمد عجاج اهلا فيك معانا
دكتور يعني المشهد اليوم اللي نحن بنشوفه
صادم الحقيقه يعني رئيس امريكي
اروح للمحكمه وبيسلم نفسه وبتطلع العواجل
انه هو الان قيد الاعتقال وتفاصيل كلبشات
وكده صادم جدا هل هذا فعلا انتصار
للديمقراطيه ولا يعني تحطيم لرمز كبير في
امريكا
طبعا يعني المنظر كما تفضلت صادم جدا لبعض
الناس ومريح جدا للبعض الاخر اذا نظرنا
الى الديمقراطيه طبعا اكبر رئيس في بلد
يعني
امبراطوريه مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يراسها رئيس وهو خرج من السلطه
والان يخضع للقانون مثله مثل اي انسان
عادي هذا انتصار كبير لمبدا الديمقراطيه
وهو المساواه امام القانون اي لا فرق بين
كبير او صغير لكن اين الاشكاليه تكمن
الاشكاليه ان مؤسسه القانون هي الان محل
شك ان هناك قسم كبير من الامريكيين يرون
ان القضاء يستخدم كاداه سياسيه للنيل من
رئيس ترامب وهذا بحد ذاته يطعن في
الديمقراطيه وبهذا الحال نجد ان هناك
انقسام كبير في البلد والمفروض من
الديمقراطيه ان تمنع هذا الانقسام وان
تجعل الناس يتفقوا على مشترك واحد لكنها
كما يبدو في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا يتفق على مشترك واحد يتفقوا على
الابتعاد عن بعضهم وربما يؤدي الى صدام
يعني هناك خلاف كبير قد ينتهي الى الشارع
لذلك الديمقراطيه في امريكا الان بقدر ما
نراها جميله الا انها مريضه بنفس الوقت
وهذا المرض اذا لم يسارع يعني الى حله في
الانتخابات القادمه من قبل الناس يعني اذا
لم ينجح ترامب تحل القضيه اما اذا نجح
الرئيس الامريكي ترامب فان الديمقراطيه
طبعا كلها ستكون يعني محل تساؤل كبير بس
حتى اذا يعني يعني انت بتقول اذا ما نجح
ترامب انه يعني حيتحسن الموضوع طب ما الان
اترمت ما هو مترشح وبايضن والديمقراطيين
في الحكم والانقسام كبير جدا يعني وملاحقه
ترامب مستمره علشان ما يدخل في الانتخابات
القادمه او هكذا يعني بيقولوا المدافعين
عنه يعني
طبعا يعني المشكله ترامب ليس قوي فقط لانه
ترامب او يتكلم ماذا يريد هو قوي لان هناك
يعني في نوع من الانقسام داخل المجتمع
الامريكي قبل ترامب وسيبقى بعد ترامب لكن
ترامب هو المحرك الماده الكيماويه التي
تجعله يتفجر ما هو هذا الانقسام ان هناك
في المجتمع الامريكي شرائح من البيض
وبالتحديد من الكنيسه
يعتقدون انهم في خطر اي انهم ليسوا اصحاب
البلد وهناك ايضا شرائح اخرى تعتبر ان
هناك طبقه من المتنفزين الماليين مع الناس
في السلطه يتحكمون بمصير الناس ويرون ان
كل ذلك لا يصح ديمقراطيا والترامب دخوله
على على الخط استطاع ان يستغل هذه الظاهره
بالذات شريحه الناس المتزمرين من رجال
المال والاعمال وغيره اما الكنيسه فرات
فيه يعني كما يقولون رجال الكنيسه خلاصا
انها امام خيارين اما ان ترى رجلا شريفا
وطيبا تستطيع ان تدعمه ويصل الى الرئاسه
ويحقق لها مطالبها مثل منع الاجهاض وقديم
وغيرها التي تعرضها الكنيسه او انها تعتمد
على ترامب لان له شعبيه مع اعتقادها انه
فاسد لكن ترى فيه مثل فيروس يعني
الامبراطور الفارسي الذي انقذ اليهود
بمعنى اخر الكنيسه تستغل ترامب للوصول الى
الاهدافها عبره هذه القضايا يعني نعم نعم
مقابل ذلك هناك الليبراليين الذين يعني
يرون ان كل هذه الامور لا يمكن القبول بها
وانه يجب ان تعطى للانسان الحريه المطلقه
وكذلك الليبراليه الماليه الشركات كل هذا
ادى الى تصادم في المجتمع الامريكي هو
الماده الكيماويه المفجره له طيب يعني
دكتور احمد خلينا نخرج حتى من خارج امريكا
العالم جالس بيتابع المشهد بالنسبه للعالم
اول شيء الكلام اللي جالس بيطلع انه في
تشكيك في القضاء الامريكي اللي دايما بيتم
تصويره بالنزاهه والمثاليه واتضح للناس
انه لا في ميول ديمقراطيه في ميول جمهوريه
وهكذا ثاني شيء منصب رئيس امريكا بمعزل
مين اللي في المنصب هذا المنصب له فخامه
يعني واهميته لما نشوف المشهد هذا الان
نحن من برا هذا ما كله بيهز كثير قيم مهمه
هم اخذتهم صينيين يصنعوها
طبعا يعني هناك نموذجان الان النموذج
الصيني والنموذج الامريكي النموذج الصيني
يقوم على قضيه انه لا يهم لون البطه كان
سوداء او بيضاء المهم ان البطه تبيض يعني
النظام الصيني يقوم على مبدا ان هناك حاكم
قوي يدير البلاد يؤمن للناس كل ما تحتاجه
من طبابه واكل وصناعه وان الحريه تعطى
بقدر معين لان اطلاقها بالكامل يكون ضرب
المجتمع هذا النموذج حتى الان في الصين
قائم واستطاعت الصين ان تحقق انجازات كبرى
النموذج الثاني هو في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والدول الديمقراطيه وهي الحريه
الشخصيه والمساواه وان الناس لهم الحق ان
يقرروا من ينتخبوا وان يعارضوه وان
يختلفوا على كل شيء لكن بالنهايه يخضع الى
القانون القانون هنا كما ذكرنا هنا
المشكله الان ان هناك تشكيك في لكن
التشكيك فيه بدا حتى مع عهد ترامب لانه هو
الذي يعني ملا المحكمه
رفض الاجابه عن اسئله بتتعلق بترمب وكان
في مؤتمر صحفي اخر للمتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض وكان لها تصريح احب نسمعه وتعلق
عليه سريعا بعد ما نسمعه تفضل
فوكس